welcome to our an introduction
I'm Barton Paulson and my goal in this
course is to introduce you to our this
is our but also this is our and then
finally this is our it's arguably the
language of data science and just so you
don't think I'm making stuff up off the
top of my head I have some actual data
this is a ranking from a survey of data
mining experts on the software that they
use most often in their work and take a
look here at the top are is first in
fact it's 50% more than Python which is
another major tool in data science and
so both of them are important but you
can see why I personally am fond of our
and why is the one that I want to start
with in introducing you to data science
now there's a few reasons that are is
especially important number one it's
free and it's open source compared to
other software packages can be thousands
of dollars per year also R is optimized
for vector operations which means you
can go through an entire row or an
entire table of data without you having
to explicitly write for loops if you've
ever had to do that then you know it's a
pain and so this is a nice thing also R
has an amazing community behind it where
you can find supportive people and you
can get examples of whatever it is you
need to do and you can get new
developments all the time plus R has
over 9,000 contributed or third-party
packages available that make it possible
to basically do anything or
you want to put it in the words of Yoda
you can say this this is our there is no
if only how and in this case I'm quoting
our user Simon Bloomberg so very briefly
in some here's why I want to introduce
you to our number one because our is the
language of data science because it's
free and it's open source and because of
the free packages that you can download
install our makes it possible to do
nearly anything when you're working with
data so I'm really glad you're here and
then I'll have this chance to show you
how you can use our to do your own work
with data and a more productive more
interesting and more effective way
thanks for joining me
the first thing that we need to do for
our an introduction is to get set up
more specifically we need to talk about
installing our the way you do this is
you can download it you just need to go
to the home page for the art project for
statistical computing and that's at our
- project.org when you get there you can
click on this link in the first
paragraph this says download our
and then I'll bring it to this page that
lists all the places that you can
download it now I find the easiest is to
simply go to this top one this has cloud
because that will automatically direct
you to whichever of the below mirrors is
best for your location when you click on
that you'll end up at this page the
comprehensive are archive network or
cran which we'll see again in this
course you need to come here and click
on your operating system if you're on a
Mac it'll take you to this page and the
version you're going to want to click on
it's just right here it's a package file
that's a zipped application installation
file click on that download it and
follow the standard installation
directions if you're on a Windows PC
then you're probably going to want this
one base again click on it download it
and go through the standard installation
procedure and if you're on a Linux
computer you're probably already
familiar with what you need to do so I'm
not going to run through that now before
we get a look at what it's actually like
when you open it there's one other thing
you need to do and that is to get the
files that we're going to be using in
this course on the page that you found
this video there's a link that says
download files if you click on that then
you'll download a zipped folder called
ro1 underscore intro underscore files
download that unzip it and if you want
to put it on your desktop when you open
it you're going to see something like
this a single folder that's on your
desktop and if you click on it
then it opens up
collection of scripts the dot our
extension is for an R source or a script
file I also have a folder with a few
data files that we'll be using in one of
these videos if you simply double-click
on this first file which full name is
this that'll open up in R and let me
show you what that looks like when you
open up the application are you will
probably get a set up of windows that
look like this on the left is the source
window or the script window where you
actually do your programming on the
right is the console window that shows
you the output and right now it's got a
bunch of boilerplate text now coming
over here again on the left any line
that begins with a pound sign or hash
tag or octothorpe
is a commented line that's not run but
these other lines are code that can be
run by the way you may notice a red
warning just popped up on the right side
that's just telling us about something
that has to do with changes in our and
it doesn't affect us what I'm going to
do right here is I'm going to put the
cursor in this line and then I'm going
to hit command or control and then enter
which will run that line and you can see
now that is opened up over here and what
I've done is I've made available to the
program a collection of data sets
and I'm going to pick one of those data
sets it's the iris data sets very well
known measurements of three species of
the iris flower and we're going to do
head to see the first six lines
and there we have the sepal length sepal
width petal length and petal width of in
this case it's also Tosa
but if you want to see a summary of the
variables get some quick descriptive
statistics we can run this next line
over here and now I get the quartiles
the mean as well as the frequency of the
three different species of virus
on the other hand is really nice to get
things visually so I'm going to run this
basic plot command for the entire data
set
and it opens up a small window I'm gonna
make it bigger
scatterplot of the measurements or the
three kinds of viruses as well as a
funny one where it's included in the
three different categories there I'm
going to close that window and so that
is basically what our looks like and how
our works in its simplest possible
version now before we leave I'm actually
going to take a moment to clean up the
application in the memory I'm going to
detach or remove the data sets package
that I added I already closed the plot
so I don't need to do this one
separately but what I can do is come
over here to clear the console I'm
actually going to come up to edit and
come down to clear console and that
cleans it out
and this is a very quick run-through of
what our looks like in its native
environment but in the next movie I'm
going to show you another application we
can install called our studio that lays
on top of this it makes interacting with
are a lot easier and a lot more
organized and really a lot more fun to
work with
the next step and are an intern
and setting up is about something called
our studio now this is our studio and
what it is is a piece of software that
you can download in addition to our what
you've already installed and its purpose
is really simple it makes working with
our easier now there's a few different
ways that it does this number one
because it has consistent command what's
funny is the different operating systems
have slightly different keyboard
commands for the same operations in our
our studio fixes that it makes it the
same whether you're on Mac Windows or
Linux also there's a unified interface
instead of having two three or seventeen
windows open you have one window with
the information organized and also it
makes it really easy to navigate with
the keyboards and to manage the
information that you have in our and let
me show you how to do this but first we
have to install it what you're going to
need to do is to go to our Studios
website which is at our studio comm from
there click on download our studio then
we'll bring it to this page or something
like it and you're going to want to
choose the desktop version now when you
get there you're going to want to
download the free sort of community
version as opposed to the thousand
dollar-a-year version
and so click here on the left
then you're going to come to the list of
installers for supported platforms
that's down here on the left this is
where you get to choose your operating
system click the top one if you have
Windows the next one if you have a Mac
and then we have lots of different
versions of Linux whichever one you get
click on it download it and go through
the standard installation process then
open it up and then let me show you what
it's like working in our studio to do
this open up this file and we'll see
what it's like in our studio
when you open up our studio you get this
one window that has several different
panes in it at the top we have the
script or the source window and this is
where you do your actual programming and
you'll see that it looks really similar
to what we did when I open up the our
application the color is a little
different but that's something that you
can change in preferences or options the
console is down here at the bottom and
that's where you get the text output
overhears the environment that saves the
variables if you're using any and then
plots and other information show up here
and the bottom right now you have the
option of rearranging things and
changing what's there as much as you
want our studio is a flexible
environment and you can resize things by
simply dragging the divider between the
areas so let me show you a quick example
using the exact same code that I did in
my previous example so you can see how
it works in our studio as opposed to the
regular our app that we use first type
first I'm going to load some data that's
by using the data sets package I'm going
to do a command or ctrl + Enter
to load that one and you can see right
here it's run the command
then I'm going to do the quick summary
of data I'm going to do head Irish shows
the first six lines
and then here it is down here I can make
that a little bit bigger if I want
then I can do a summary by just coming
back here and clicking command or
control enter
and actually I'm going to do a keyboard
command to make the console a bigger now
and then we can see all of that I have
the same basic descriptive statistics
and the same frequencies there you can
go back to how it was before and make
this bring this one down a little and
now we can do the plot
now this time you see it shows up in
this window here on the side which is
nice it's not a standalone window let me
make that one bigger it takes a moment
to adjust and there we have the same
information that we had in the our app
but here it's more organized in a
cohesive environment and you see that
I'm using keyboard shortcuts to move
around and it makes life really easy for
dealing with the information that I have
in our
I'm gonna do the same clean up I'm going
to detach the package that I had this is
actually a little command to clear the
plots and then here in our studio I can
run a funny little command that'll do
the same as doing control L to clear the
console for me and that is a quick
run-through of how you can do some very
basic coding in our studio again which
makes working with our more organized
more efficient and easier to do overall
in our very basic introduction to our
and setting up there's one more thing I
want to mention that makes working with
our really amazing and that the packages
that you can download install basically
you can think of them as giving you
superpowers when you're doing your
analysis because you can basically do
anything with the packages that are
available specifically packages are
bundles of code so it's more software
that adds new function to our makes it
so it can do new things now there are
two kinds of package two general
categories there are base packages these
are packages that are installed with our
so they're already there but they're not
loaded by default that way our doesn't
use maybe as much memory as it might
otherwise but more significant than that
are the contributed or third-party
packages these are packages that need to
be downloaded installed and then loaded
separately and when you get those it
makes things extraordinary and so you
may ask yourself where to get these
marvelous packages that make things so
SuperDuper well you have a few choices
number one you can go to cran that's the
comprehensive our archive network that's
an official our site that has things
listed with the official documentation
too you can go to a site called cran
tastic which really is just a way of
listing these things and when you click
on the links it redirect you back to
crayon
and then third you can also get our
packages from github which is an
entirely different process if you're
familiar with github it's not a big deal
otherwise you don't usually need to deal
with it but let's start with this first
one
the comprehensive our archive network or
cran
now we saw this previously when we were
just downloading our this time we're
going to cran dot R - project.org and
we're specifically looking for this one
the cran packages that's going to be
right here on the left click on packages
and when you open that you're going to
have an interesting option and that's to
go to task views and that breaks it down
by topic so we have here packages that
deal with Bayesian inference packages
that deal with chemometrics and
computational physics so on and so forth
if you click on any one of those it'll
give you a short description of the
packages that are available and what
they're designed to do now another place
to get packages I said is cran tastic at
cran tastic org and this is one that
lists the most recently updated the most
popular packages and it's a nice way of
getting some sort of information about
what people use most frequently although
it does redirect you back to cran to do
the actual downloading
and then finally at github.com if you go
to slash trending slash art you'll see
the most common or most frequently
downloaded packages on github for use in
our now regardless of how you get it let
me show you the ones that I use most
often and I find these make working with
art really a lot more effective and a
lot easier now they have kind of cryptic
names the first one is deep liar which
is for manipulating data frames then
there's tidier for cleaning up
information stringer for working with
strings or text information [ __ ] date
for manipulating date information HTT
are for working with website data ggv is
where the GG stands for a grammar of
graphics this is for interactive
visualizations ggplot2 is probably the
most common package for creating
graphics or data visualizations in our
SHINee is another one that allows you to
create interactive applications that you
can install on websites Rio is for our
input/output it's for importing and
exporting data and then our markdown
allows you to create what are called
interactive notebooks or rich documents
for sharing your information now there
are others but there's one in particular
the things useful I call it the one
package to load them all and it's
pac-man which not surprisingly stands
for package manager and I'm going to
demonstrate all of these and another
course that we have here but let me show
you very quickly how to get them working
you just try it in our if you open up
this file from the course files let me
show you what it looks like what we have
here in our studio is the file for this
particular video and I say that I use
pac-man if you don't have it installed
already then run this one installation
line this is the standard installation
command in our and they'll add pac-man
and then it will show up here and
packages now I already have it installed
and so you can see it right there but
it's not currently loaded see cuz
installing means making it available on
your hard drive but loading means
actually making it accessible to your
current routines so then I need to load
it or import it and I can do it with one
of two ways
I can use the require which gives a
confirmation message I can do it like
this and you see it's got that little
sentence there or I can do library which
simply loads it without saying anything
you can see now by the way that it's
checked off so we know it's there now if
you have pac-man installed even if it's
not loaded then you can actually use
pac-man to install other packages so
what I actually do is because I have
pac-man installed I just go straight to
this one you do pac-man and then the two
colons it says use this command even
though this package isn't loaded and
then I load an entire collection all the
things that I showed you
starting with pac-man itself so now I'm
going to run this command
and what's nice about pac-man is if you
don't have the package it will actually
install it make it available and load it
and I got it so this is a much easier
way to do it then the standard our
routine
and then for base packages that means
the ones that come with are natively
like the datasets package you still want
to do it this way you load and unload
them separately so now I've got that one
available and then I can do the work
that I want to do now I'm actually not
going to do it right now because I'm
going to show it to you in future videos
but now I have a whole collection of
packages available they're going to give
me a lot more functionality and make my
work more effective I'm going to finish
by simply unloading what I have here now
if you want to with pac-man you can
unload specific packages or the easiest
ways to do P underscore unload all and
what that does is it unloads all of the
add-on or contributed third-party
packages
and you can see I've got the full list
there of what it's unloaded however for
the base packages like data sets use
need to use this standard our command
and detach which I'll use right here
and then I'll clear my console and
that's a very quick run-through of how
packages can be found online installed
into our and loaded to make your code
more available and I'll demonstrate how
those work and basically every video
from here on out so you'll be able to
see how to exploit their functionality
to make your work a lot faster and a lot
easier
probably the best place to start when
you're working with any statistics
program is basic graphics so you can get
a quick visual impression of what you're
dealing with and the command in art that
makes that simplest of all is the
default plot command it's also known as
basic XY plotting for the x and y axes
on the graph and what's neat about ours
plot command is that it adapts to data
types and to the number of variables
that you're dealing with now it's going
to be a lot easier for me to simply show
you how this works so let's try it in
our
just open up the script file and we'll
see how we can do some basic
visualizations in our the first thing
that we're going to do is load some
datasets from the datasets package that
comes with our we simply do library
datasets and that loads it up we're
going to use the iris data which I've
showed you before and you'll get to see
many more times let's look at the first
few lines I'll zoom in on that
and what this is is the measurement of
the sepal and petal length and width for
three species of irises is very famous
datasets about a hundred years old
and it's a great way of getting a quick
feel for what we're able to do in our
I'll come back to the full window here
and what we're going to do is first get
a little information about the plot
command to get help on something in our
just do the question mark and the thing
you want help for
our studio so this opens up right here
in the help window and you see we've got
the whole set of information here all
the parameters and additional links you
can click on and then examples here at
the bottom
I'm going to come over here and I'm
going to use the command for a
categorical variable first and that's
the most basic kind of data that we have
and so species which is three different
species is what I want to use right here
so I'm going to do plot and then in the
parentheses you put what it is you want
to plot and what I'm doing here is I'm
saying it's in the data set iris that's
our data frame actually and then the
dollar sign says use this variable
that's in that data so that's how you
specify the whole thing
and then we get an extremely simple
three bar chart I'll zoom in on it
and what it tells you is that we have
three species of iris setosa versicolor
and virginica and then we have 50 of
each and so it's nice to know that we
have balanced group that we have three
groups because that might affect some of
the analyses that you do and it's an
extremely quick and easy way to begin
looking at the data I'll zoom back out
now let's look at a quantitative
variable sub one that's on an interval
or nominal level of measurement for this
one I'll do petal length and you see I
do the same thing plot and then iris and
then pedaling
please note I'm not telling are that
this is now a quantitative variable on
the other hand it's able to figure that
one out by itself now this one's a
little bit funny because it's a scatter
plot I'm going to zoom in on it but the
x-axis is the index number or the row
number in the data set so that one's
really not helpful
it's the variable that's going on the
why that's the petal length that you get
to see the distribution on the other
hand you know that we have 50 of each
species and we have thus Atossa and then
we have the versicolor and then we have
the virginica and so you can see that
there are group differences on these
three things
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
ask for a specific kind of plot to break
it down more explicitly between the two
categories that is I'm going to put in
two variables now where I have my
categorical species and then a comma and
then the pedal length which is my
quantitative measurement I'm going to
run that again you just hit controller
command and enter
and this is one that I'm looking for
here let's zoom in on that again you see
that it's adapted and it knows for
instance that the first variable I gave
it is categorical the second one is
quantitative and the most common chart
for that is a box plot and so that's
what it automatically chooses to do and
you can see it's a good plot here we can
see very strong separation between the
groups on this particular measurement
I'll zoom back out
and then let's try a quantitative pair
so now I'll do pedal length and pedal
width so it's going to be a little bit
different I'll run that command and now
this one is a proper scatterplot where
we have a measurement across the bottom
and a measurement up the side but you
can see that there's a really strong
positive association between these two
so not surprisingly as a pedal gets
longer it generally also gets wider so
it just gets bigger overall
and then finally if I want to run the
plot command on the entire data set the
entire data frame this is what happens
we do plot and then iris now we've seen
this one in previous examples but let me
zoom in on it
and what it is is an entire matrix of
scatter plots of the four quantitative
variables and then we have species which
is kind of funny because it's not
labeling them but it shows us a dot plot
for the measurements of each species and
this is a really nice way if you don't
have too many variables of getting a
very quick holistic impression of what's
going on in your data and so the point
of this is that the default plot command
is able to adapt to the number of
variables I gave it and to the kind of
variables I give it and it makes life
really easy now I want you to know that
it's possible to change the way that
these look I'm going to specify some
options I'm going to do the plot again
the scatter plot or I say plot and then
in parentheses I give these two
arguments or saying what I want in it
I'm gonna say do the petal length and do
the petal width and then I'm gonna go to
another line I'm just separating with
commas now if you want to you can write
this always one really long line I break
it up because I think it makes a little
more readable I'm going to specify the
color I knew with call for color and
then I use a hex code and that code is
actually for the red that is used on the
data lab homepage and then PCH is for
point character and that is a 19 is a
solid circle then I'm going to main
title on it then I'm gonna put a label
on the x-axis and a label on the y-axis
so I'm actually going to run those now
by in doing command or control enter for
each line and you can see it builds up
and when we finished we got the whole
thing all zooming on it again
and this is the kind of thought that you
could actually use in a presentation or
possibly in a publication and so even
with the base command were able to get
really good-looking informative clean
and graphs
now what's interesting is that the plot
command can do more than just show data
we can actually feed it in formulas if
you want for instance to get a cosign
I do plot and then Coast is for cosine
and then I give the limit I go from zero
to two times pi because that's relevant
for cosine I click on that and you can
see the graph there it's doing our
little cosine curve I can do an
exponential distribution from one to
five
and there it is curving up and I can do
D norm which is for a density of a
normal distribution from minus 3 to plus
3 and there's the good old bell curve
there in the bottom right and then we
can use the same kind of options that we
used earlier for our scatter plot here
going to say do a plot of D norm so the
bell curve from minus 3 to plus 3 on the
x-axis but now we're going to change the
color to red lwd is for line width make
it thicker give it a title on the top a
label on the x-axis and the label on the
y-axis well zoom in on that and so there
is my new and improved prettier and
presentation ready bell curve that I got
with a default plot command and our
and so this is a really flexible and
powerful command also it's the base
package and you'll see that we have a
lot of other commands that can do even
more elaborate things but this is a
great way to start and get a quick
impression of your data see what you're
dealing with and shape the analyses that
you do subsequently
the next step in our introduction and
our discussion of basic graphics is bar
charts and the reason I like to talk
about bar charts is this because simple
is good and when it comes to bar charts
bar charts are the most basic graphic
for the most basic data and so they're a
wonderful place to start in your
analysis let me show you how this works
just try it in our open up this script
and let's run through and see how it
works when you open up the file in our
studio the first thing we're going to
want to do is come down here and open up
the data sets package
and then we're going to scroll down a
little bit and we're gonna use a dataset
called Mt cars let's get a little bit of
information about this do the question
mark in the name of the dataset
this is Motor Trend that's a magazine
car Road tests from 1974 so you know
there are 42 years old let's take a look
at the first few rows of what's in Mt
cars by doing head
and I'm going to zoom in on this
and what you can see is that we have a
list of cars the Mazda rx4 and the wagon
the Datsun 710 the AMC Hornet and I
actually remember these cars and we have
several variables on each of them we
have the mpg miles per gallon we have
the number cylinders the displacement in
cubic inches the horsepower the final
drive ratio which has to do with the
axle and then we have the weight and
tons the quarter mile time in seconds
and these are a bunch of really really
slow cars vs is for whether the
cylinders are in a V or whether they are
in a straight or inline and then the Am
is for automatic or manual then we go
down to the next line we have gear which
is the number of gears in the
transmission and carb for how many
carburetor barrels they have which is we
don't even use carburetors anymore
anyhow so that's what's in the data set
I'll zoom back out
now if we want to do a really basic bar
chart you might think that the most
obvious thing to do would be to use ours
bar plot command that's its name for the
bar chart and then to specify the data
set MD cars and then the dollar sign and
then the variables that we want
cylinders so you think that would work
but unfortunately it doesn't instead
what we get is this which is just kind
of going through all the cases on a one
by one by one row and telling us how
many cylinders are in that case that's
not a good one that's not what we want
and so what we need to do is we actually
need to reformat the data a little bit
by the way you would have to do the
exact same thing if you wanted to make a
bar chart in a spreadsheet like Excel or
Google sheets it can't do it with the
raw data you first need to create a
summary table and so what we're going to
do here is we're going to use the
command table I'm going to say take this
variable from this data set and make a
table of it and feed it into an object
you know a data thing data container
called cylinders I'm going to run that
one
and then you see that just showed up in
the top left let me zoom in on that one
so now I have in my environment a data
object called cylinders it's a table
it's got a length of three it's got a
size of 1,000 bytes and it gives us a
little bit more information let's go
back to where we were
but now I've saved that information into
cylinders which just has the number of
cylinders I can run the bar plot command
and now I get the kind of plot I
expected to see from this we see that we
have a fair number of cars with four
cylinders a smaller number with six and
because this is in 74 we've got a lot of
8 cylinder cars in this particular data
set now we can also use the default plot
command which I showed you previously on
the same data but it's going to do
something a little different it's
actually going to make a line chart
where the lines are the same length of
each bars I probably use the bar plot
instead because it's easier to tell
what's going on but this is a way of
making a default chart that gives you
the information you need for the
categorical variables remember simple is
good and that's a great way to start in
our last video on basic graphics we
talked about bar charts
if you have a quantitative variable then
the most basic kind of chart is a
histogram and this is for data that is
quantitative or scaled or measured or
interval or ratio level all of those are
referring to basically the same thing
and in all of those you want to get an
idea of what you have and a histogram
allows you to see what you have now
there's a few things you're going to be
looking for it with a histogram number
one you're going to be looking for this
shape of the distribution is it
symmetrical as it skewed is a unimodal
bimodal you're going to look for gaps or
big empty spaces in the distribution
you're also going to look for outliers
unusual scores because those can distort
any of your subsequent analyses you look
for symmetry to see whether you have the
same number of high and lowest scores or
whether you have to do some sort of
adjustment to the distribution but this
is going to be easier if we just try it
in our so open up this our script file
and let's take a look at how we can do
histograms in our
when you open up the file the first
thing we need to do is come down here
and load the data sets we'll do this by
running the library command I just do
ctrl or command enter
and then we can do the iris dataset
again we've looked at it before but
let's get a little bit of information
from it by asking for help on iris
and there we have Edgar Anderson's IRS
data also known as Fisher's iris data
because he published an article on it
and here's the full set of information
available on it from 1936 huh that's 80
years old let's take a look at the first
few rows and again we've seen this
before
sepal and petal length and width for
three species of iris we're going to do
a basic histogram on the four
quantitative variables that are in here
and so I'm going to use just the hist
command so hist and then the data set
iris and then the dollar sign to say
which variable and then siebel dot
length when I run that I get my first
histogram let's zoom in on a little bit
and what happens here is of course it's
a basic sort of black line on white
background which is fine for exploratory
graphics and it gives us a default title
this is histogram of the variable and it
gives us the the clunky name which is
also on the x-axis on the bottom it
automatically adjusts the x axis and it
chooses about seven or nine bars which
is usually the best choice for a
histogram and then on the left it gives
us the frequency or the count of how
many observations are in that group so
for instance we have only five irises
whose sepal length is between four and
four and a half centimeters I think it
is let's zoom back out
and let's do another one now this time
for a sepal width you can see that's
almost a perfect bell curve if we do
petal length we get something different
let me zoom in on that one
and this is where we see a big gap we've
got a really strong bar there at the low
end in fact it goes above the frequency
axis and then we have a gap and then
sort of a bell curve that lets us know
that there's something interesting going
on with the data that we're going to
want to explore a little more fully
and then we'll do another one for petal
width I'll just run this command and you
can see the same kind of pattern here
where there's a big clump at the low end
there's a gap and then there's sort of a
bell curve beyond that
now another way to do this is to do the
histograms by groups and that would be
an obvious thing to do here because we
have three different species of iris so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to put the graphs into three rows
one above another in one column I'm
going to do this by changing a parameter
P AR s for parameter and I'm giving it
the number of rows that I want to have
in my output and I need to give it a
combination of numbers I do this C which
is for concatenate that means treat
these two numbers as one unit where 3 is
the number of rows and then the 1 is the
number of columns so I run that it
doesn't show anything just yet and then
I'm going to come down and I'm going to
do this more elaborate command I'm going
to do hist that's the histogram that
we've been doing I'm going to do petal
length except this time in square
brackets I'm going to put a selector
it's this means you use only these rows
and the way I do this is by saying I
want to do it for this Atossa
irises so I say iris that's the data set
and then dollar sign and then species of
the variable and then 2 equals because
in computers that means is equivalent to
and then in quotes and I have to spell
it exactly the same with the same
capitalization I do it's atossa so this
is the variable and the row selection
I'm also going to put in some limits for
the X because I want to manually make
sure that all three of the histograms I
have have the same X scale so I'm going
to specify that breaks is for how many
bars I want in the histogram and and
actually what's funny about this is it's
really only a suggestion that you give
to the computer then I'm going to put a
title above that one I'm going to have
no X label and I'm going to make it red
so I'm going to do all of that right now
I'll just run each line
and then you see I have a very skinny
chart let's zoom in on it
and so it's very short but that's
because I'm gonna have multiple charts
and it's going to make more sense when
we look at them all together you can see
by the way that the pedal width for the
seat Osiris's is on the low end
now let's do the same thing for a
versicolor I'm going to run through all
that
it's all going to be the same except
we're gonna make it purple there's
various of color and then let's do
virginica last
and we'll make those blue
and now I can zoom
there
and no one we have our three histograms
it's the same variable pedal with but
now I'm doing it separately for each of
the three species and it's really easy
to see what's going on here now Satou
says really low versicolor in virginica
overlap but they're still distinct
distributions this approach by the way
is referred to as small multiples making
many versions of the same chart on the
same scale so it's really easy to
compare across groups or across
conditions which is what we're able to
do right here now by the way anytime you
change the graphical parameters you want
to make sure to change them back to what
they were before so here I'm going par
and then going back to one column and
one row and that's a good way of doing
histograms for examining quantitative
variables and even for exploring some of
the complications that can arise when
you have different categories with
different scores on those variables
in our two previous videos we looked at
some basic graphics for one variable at
a time we looked at bar charts for
categorical variables and we look at
histograms for quantitative variables
and while there's a lot more you can do
with univariate distributions you also
might want to look at bivariate
distributions we're gonna look at
scatter plots as the most common version
of that you do a scatter plot when what
you want to do is visualize the
association between two quantitative
variables now I actually know it's more
flexible than that but this is the
canonical case for a scatter plot and
when you do that what sorts of things do
you want to look for in your scatter
plot I mean there's a purpose in it well
number one you want to see if the
association between your two variables
is linear or if it can be described by a
straight line because most of the
procedures that we do assume linearity
you also want to check if you have
consistent spread across the scores as
you go from one end to the x axis to
another because if things fan out
considerably then you have what's called
heteroscedasticity and it can really
complicate some of the other analyses as
always you want to look for outliers
because an unusual score or especially
unusual combination this course can
drastically throw off some of your other
interpretations and then you want to
look for the correlation is there an
association between these two variables
so that's what we're looking for let's
try it in our simply open up this file
and let's see how it works
the first thing we need to do in our is
come down and open up the data sets
package
just to command or control and enter and
we'll load the data sets we're going to
use empty cars we looked at that before
it's got a little bit of information
it's Road test data from 1974 and let's
look at the first few cases I'll zoom in
on that thinking we have miles per
gallon cylinders so on and so forth
now anytime you're going to do an
association it's a really good idea to
look at the univariate or one variable
at a time distributions as well we're
going to look at the associations
between weight and miles per gallon so
let's look at the distribution for each
of those separately I'll do that with a
histogram I do hist and then in
parentheses I specified the data set
empty cars in this case and then the
dollar sign to say which variable in
that data set
so there's the histogram for weight and
you know it's not horrible though it
looks like we got a few on the high end
there and here's the histogram for miles
per gallon again mostly kind of normal
but a few on the high end but let's look
at the plot of the two of them together
now what's interesting is I just used
the generic plot command I feed that in
and R is able to tell that I'm giving it
two quantitative variables and that a
scatterplot is the best kind of plot for
that so we're going to do weight and
miles per gallon and then let me zoom in
on that
and what you see here is one circle for
each car at the joint position of its
weight and it's miles per gallon and
it's a strong downhill pattern not
surprisingly the Mora car weighs and we
have some in this data set that are 5
tonnes the lower its miles per gallon we
have get down to about 10 miles per
gallon here the smallest cars which
appeared away substantially under two
tons get about 30 miles per gallon
now this is probably adequate for most
purposes but there's a few other things
that we can do so for instance I'm going
to add some colors here I'm going to
take the same plot and then add on
additional arguments or say use a solid
circle PCHS for point character 19 as a
solid circle cex has to do with the size
of things and I'm going to make it a 1.5
means make them a hundred and 50 percent
larger
call is for color and I'm specifying a
particular red the one for data lab in
hex code I'm going to give a title I'm
going to give it an X label and a while
label and then we'll zoom in on that and
now we have a more polished chart that
also because of the solid red circles
makes it easier to see the pattern
that's going in there where we got some
really heavy cars with a really bad gas
mileage and an almost perfect linear
Association up to the lighter cars was
much better gas mileage
and so a scatterplot is the easiest way
of looking at the association between
two variables especially when those two
variables are quantitative so they're on
the scaled or measured outcome and
that's something that you want to do
anytime you're doing your analysis to
first visualize it and then use that as
the introduction to any numerical or
statistical work you do after that
as we go through our necessarily very
short presentations on basic graphics I
want to finish by saying one more thing
and that is you have the possibility of
overlaying plots and that means putting
one plot directly on top of or
superimposing it on another now you may
ask yourself why you want to do this
well I can give you an artistic version
on this this of course is Pablo Picasso
is laid Emma's Ella d'Avignon and it's
one of the early masterpieces in cubism
and the idea of cubism is it gives you
many views or it gives you
simultaneously several different
perspectives on the same thing and we're
going to try to do a similar thing with
data and so we can say very quickly
thanks Pablo now why would you overlay
plots really if you want the technical
explanation is because you get increased
information density you get more
information and hopefully more insight
in the same amount of space and
hopefully the same amount of time now
there is a potential risk here you might
be saying to yourself at this point well
you want dense guess what I can do dance
and then we end up with something
vaguely like this the Garden of Earthly
Delights and it's completely
overwhelming and it just makes you kind
of shut down cognitively and you know
thank you Hieronymus Bosch no I instead
well I like hieronymus Bosch's at work
let me tell you when it comes to data
graphics use restraint just because you
can do something doesn't mean that you
should do that thing when it comes to
graphics and overlaying plots the
general rule is this use views that
complement and support one another that
don't compete but that give greater
information in a coherent and consistent
way this is going to make a lot more
sense if we just take a look at how it
works in our so open up this script and
we'll see how we can overlay plots for
greater information density and greater
insight
the first thing that we're going to need
to do is open up the data sets package
and we're going to be using a data set
we haven't used before about Lynx's
that's the animal this is about Canadian
lynx trappings from 1821 to 1934 if you
want the actual information on the data
set there it is
now let's take a look at the first few
lines of data this one is a time series
and so what's unusual about it is is
it's just one line of numbers and you
have to know that it starts at 1821 it
goes through so let's make a default
chart with a histogram as a way of seen
were links trappings consistent or how
much variability was there we'll do hist
which is the default histogram and we'll
simply put links in we don't have to
specify variables because there's only
one variable in it and when we do that
I'll zoom in on that we get really a
skewed distribution most of the
observations are down at the low end and
then it tapers off too it's actually
measured in thousands and so we can tell
that there is a very common value it's
at the low end and then on the other
hand we don't know what years those were
so we're ignoring that for just a moment
and take a look at the overall
distribution of trappings regardless of
years let me zoom back out and we can do
some options on this one to make it a
little more intricate we can do a
histogram and then if in parentheses I
specify the data I also can tell it how
many bins I want and again it sort of is
suggesting it because R is going to do
what it wants any help I can say make it
a density instead of frequency so it'll
give proportions of the total
distribution will change the color to
called thistle one because you can use
color names and are
we'll give it a title here by the way
I'm using the paste command because it's
a long title and I want it to show up on
the one line but I need to spread my
command across two lines you can go
longer I have to use a short command
line so you can actually see what we do
when we're zoomed in here
so there's that one and then we're going
to give it a label this has a number of
links trapped
and now we have a more elaborate chart
I'll zoom in on it and it's a kind of
little thistle purple lilac color
and we have divided the number of Bin's
differently previously it was one bar
for every 1000 now it's one bar for 500
but that's just one chart we're here to
see how we can overlay charts and a
really good one anytime you're dealing
with a histogram is a normal
distribution so you want to see are the
data distributed normally and we can
tell they're skewed here but let's get
an idea of how far they are from normal
to do this we use the command curve and
then D norm is for a density of the
normal distribution and then here I tell
it X is you know just a generic variable
name but I tell it use the mean of the
links data use the standard deviation of
the links data we'll make it a slightly
different thistle color number for we'll
make it two pixels wide the line width
is two pixels and then add says stick it
on the previous graph and so now I'll
zoom in on that and you can see if we
had a normal distribution with the same
mean and standard deviation as this data
it would look like that obviously that's
not what we have because we have this
great big spike here on the low end
then I can do a couple of other things I
can put in what are called kernel
density estimators and those are sort of
like a bell curve except they're not
parametric and said they follow the
distribution of the data that means they
can have a lot more curves in them they
still add up to one like a normal
distribution so let's see what those
would look like here we're going to do
lines that's what we use for this one
and then we see a density that's going
to be the standard kernel density
estimator will make it blue
and there it is on top I'm going to do
one more than will zoom in I can change
a parameter of the kernel density
estimator here I'm using adjust to say
average across it's sort of like a
moving average average across a little
more and they'll let me zoom in on that
and you can see for instance that the
blue line follows the spike at the low
end a lot more closely and then it dips
down on the other hand the purple line
is a lot more slow to change because of
the way I gave it its instructions with
the adjust equals three
and then I'm going to add one more thing
something called a rug plot it's a
little vertical lines underneath the
plot for each individual data point and
I do that with rug and I say just use
links and then we're going to make it a
line width or pixel width of two and
then we'll make it gray
that and a zooming is our final plot you
can see now that we have the individual
observations marked and you can see why
each bar is as tall as it is and why the
kernel density estimator follows the
distribution that it does this is our
final histogram with several different
views of the same data it's not cubism
but it's a great way of getting a richer
view of even a single variable that can
then inform the subsequent analyses you
do to get more meaning and more utility
out of your data
you
continuing and our an introduction the
next thing we need to talk about is
basic statistics and we'll begin by
discussing the basic summary function in
R the idea here is that once you have
done the pictures that you've done the
basic visualizations then you're going
to want to get some precision by getting
numerical or statistical information
depending on the kinds of variables you
have you're going to want different
things so for instance you're going to
want counts or frequencies for
categories and they're going to want
things like quartiles and the mean for
quantitative variables we can try this
in R and you'll see that it's a very
very simple thing to do just open up the
script and follow along
what we're going to do is load the data
sets package controller command and then
enter
and we're actually going to look at some
data and do an analysis that we've seen
several times already we're going to
lower the iris data and let's take a
look at the first few lines
and again this is for quantitative
measurements on the sepal and petal
length and width are three species of
iris flowers
and what we're going to do is we're
going to get summary in three different
ways first we're going to do summary for
a categorical variable
and the way we do this is we use the
summary function and then we'd say iris
cuz that's the data set and then a
dollar sign and then the name of the
variable that we want so in this case
it's species we'll run that command and
you can see it just has Satou so 50
versicolor 50 and virginica 50 and those
are the frequencies are the counts for
each of those three categories in the
species variable now we're going to get
something more elaborate for the
quantitative variable will use sepal
length for that one and I'll just run
that next line
and now you can see it lays it out
horizontally we have the minimum value
of four point three then we have the
first quartile of five point one the
median then the mean then the third
quartile and then the maximum score of
seven point nine and so this is a really
nice way of getting a quick impression
of the spread discourse and also by
comparing the median and the mean
sometimes you can tell whether it's
symmetrical or their skewness going on
and then you have one more option and
that is getting a summary for the entire
data frame or data set at once and what
I do is I simply do summary and then in
the parenthesis for the argument I just
give the name of the data set iris
and this one I need to zoom in a little
bit because now it arranges it
vertically where we do sepal length so
that's our first variable and we get the
quartiles and we get the median and we
do see people with pedal lengths pedal
width and then it switches over at the
last one species where it gives us the
counts or frequencies of each of those
three categories and so that's the most
basic version of what you're able to do
with the default summary variable in our
gives you quick descriptives gives you
the precision to follow up on some of
the graphics that we did previously and
it gets you ready for your further
analyses
as you're starting to work with our own
you're getting basic statistics you may
find you want a little more information
than the base summary function gives you
in that case you can use something
called describe and this purpose is
really easy
it gets more detail now this is not
included in ours base functionality
instead this comes from a contributed
package it comes from the psych package
and when you run describe from a site
this is what you're going to get you'll
get n that's the sample size the mean
the standard deviation the median the
10% trimmed mean the median absolute
deviation the minimum maximum values the
range skewness and kurtosis and standard
errors now don't forget you still want
to do this after you do your graphical
summaries pictures first numbers later
but let's see how this works in our
simply open up this script and we'll run
through it step by step
when you open up our the first thing
we're going to need to do is we're going
to need to install the package now I'm
actually going to go through my default
installation of packages because I'm
going to use one of these pac-man and
this just makes things a little bit
easier so we're going to load all of
these packages and this assumes of
course that you have pac-man installed
already we're going to get the data sets
and then we'll load our iris data we've
done that lots of times before
sepal and petal length and width and the
species but now we're going to do
something a little different we're gonna
load a package I'm using P load from the
pac-man package that's that's why I
loaded it already and this will download
it if you don't have it already
it might take a moment and it downloads
a few dependencies generally other
packages that need to come along with it
now if you want to get some help on it
dupy anytime you have P an underscore
that's something from pac-man P help
psych now when you do that it's going to
open up a web browser and it's going to
get the PDF help I've got it open
already because it's really big in fact
it's 367 pages here of documentation
about the functions in Psych
obviously we're not going to do the
whole thing here
what we are going to do is we can look
at some of it in the our viewer if you
simply add this argument here web equals
F for fall so you can spell out the word
false as long as you do it in all caps
then it opens up here on the right and
here is actually this is a web browser
this is a web page we're looking at and
each of these you can click on and get
information about the individual bits
and pieces now let's use describe that
comes from this package it's for
quantitative variables only so you don't
you want to use it for categories what
we're going to do here
we're going to pick one quantitative
variable right now and that is iris and
then sepal length
when we run that one here's what we get
now we get a list here a line the first
number the one simply indicates the row
number we only have one row so that's
what we have anyhow and it gives us the
N of 150 the mean of 5.8 for the
standard deviation the median so on and
so forth out to the standard error there
at the end
now that's for one quantitative variable
if you want to do more than that or
especially if you want to do an entire
data frame just give the name of the
data frame in describe so here we go
describe iris
and I'm going to zoom in on that one
because now we have a lot of stuff now
it lists all the variables down this
side sepal length and it gives the
variables numbers 1 2 3 4 5 and it gives
us the information for each one of them
please note it's given us numerical
information for species but it shouldn't
be doing that because that's a
categorical variable so you can ignore
that last line that's why I put in the
asterisk right there but otherwise this
gives you more detailed information
including things like the standard
deviation in the skewness that you might
need to get a more complete picture of
what you have in your data i used to
describe a lot it's a great way to
compliment histograms and other charts
like box plots to give you a more
precise image of your data and prepare
you for your other analyses
to finish up our section and our an
introduction on basic statistics let's
take a short look at selecting cases
what this does is it allows you to focus
your analysis choose particular cases
and look at them more closely now in
alright you can do this a couple of
different ways you can select by
category if you have the name of a
category or you can select by value on a
scaled variable or you can select by
both let me show you how this works in
our just open up this script and we'll
take a look at how it works
as with most of our other examples we'll
begin by loading the data sets package
and by using library just ctrl or
command enter to run that command that's
now loaded and we'll use the IRS data
set so we'll look at the first few cases
head irises how we do that
zoom in on it for a second there's the
iris data we've already seen it several
times
and we'll come down and we'll make a
histogram of the petal length for all of
the irises and the data set so iris is
the name of the data set and then petal
length
there's our histogram off to the right
I'll zoom in on it for a second
see of course that we've got this group
stuck way at the left and then we have a
gap right here then we have a pretty
much normal distribution the rest of it
zoom back out we can also get some
summary statistics I'll do that right
here for a petal length there we have
the minimum value of the quartiles and
the mean now let's do one more thing and
let's get the name of the species that's
art going to be our categorical variable
and the number of cases four of each
species so I do summary and then it
knows that this is a categorical
variable so we run it through and we
have 50 of each that's good the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to select cases by their category in
this case by the species of virus we'll
do this three times we'll do it once for
versicolor
so I'm going to do histogram or I say
use the iris data and then dollar sign
means use this variable petal length and
then in square brackets I put this to
indicate select these rows or select
these cases and I say select when this
variable species is equals you got to
use the two equal signs to versicolor
make sure you spell it and capitalize it
exactly as it appears in the data then
we'll put a title on it this says petal
length versicolor so here we go
and there is our selected cases this is
just 50 cases going to the histogram now
on the bottom right we'll do a similar
thing for virginica where we simply
change our selection criteria from
versicolor to virginica
and we get a new title there and then
finally we can do it first atossa also
so great that's three different
histograms by selecting values on a
categorical variable where you just type
them in quotes exactly as they appear in
the data now another way to do this is
to select by value on a quantitative or
scale two variable we want to do that
what you do is in the square brackets to
indicate you're selecting rows you put
the variable I'm specifying that it's in
the IRS data set and then say what value
you're selecting I'm looking for values
less than two and I have the title
change to reflect that now what's
interesting is this selects the cytosis
it's the exact same group and so the
diagram doesn't change but the titles
and the method of selecting the cases
did probably a more interesting one is
when you want to use multiple selectors
let's look for virginica that'll be our
species and we want short petals only so
this says what variable were using petal
length and this is how we select we say
Iris dollar-sign species so that tells
us which variable is equal to with the
two equals of virginica and then I just
put an ampersand and then say iris petal
length is less than 5.5 and I can run
that
I get my new title
in on it
and so what we have here are just
virginica but the shorter ones and so
this is a pair of selectors used
simultaneously
now another way to do this by the way is
if you know you're going to be using the
same sub sample many times you might as
well create a new data set that has just
those cases and the way you do that is
you specify the data that you're
selecting from then in square brackets
the rows and the columns and then you
use the assignment operator that's the
less than and dash here which you can
read as get so so I'm going to create
one called
eye dots Atossa for iris setosa and I'm
going to do it by going to the iris data
and in species reading justice Atossa I
then put a comma because this one
selects the rows I need to tell it which
columns if I want all of them you just
leave it blank so I'm going to do that
and now I see I'm up here in the top
right I'll zoom in on it I now have a
new object new data object in the
environment is a data frame called
aissatou so
and we can look at that sub sample that
I've just created we'll get the head of
just those cases now you see it looks
just the same as the other ones except
it only has 50 cases as opposed to 150
and get a summary for those cases and
this time I'm doing just the pedal
length
also get a histogram for the pedal
length and it's going to be just these
two ptosis and so that's several ways of
dealing with sub samples and again
saving this election if you're going to
be using it multiple times it allows you
to drill down on the data and get a more
focused picture of what's going on and
helps inform your analyses that you
carry on from this point
the next step in our an introduction is
to talk about accessing data and to get
that started we need to say a little bit
about data formats and the reason for
that is sometimes your data you're
select talking about apples and oranges
you have fundamentally different kinds
of things now there are two ways in
particular that this can happen the
first one is you can have data of
different types different data types and
then regardless of the type you can have
your data in different structures and
it's important to understand each of
these we'll start by talking about data
types this is like the level of a
measurement of a variable you can have
numeric variables which usually come in
integer whole number or single precision
or double precision you can have
character variables with text in them we
don't have string variables in our
they're all character you can have
logical which are true false or
otherwise called boolean you can have
complex numbers and you can have a data
type raw but regardless of which kind
that you have you can arrange them into
different data structures the most
common structures are vector matrix or
array data frame and list we'll take a
look at each of these
a vector is one or more numbers in a
one-dimensional array I mention them all
in a straight line now what's
interesting here is that in other
situations if it's a single number it
would be called a scalar but in R it's
still a vector is just a vector of
length 1 the important thing about
vectors is that the data are all of the
same data type so for instance all
character or all integer and you can
think of this as ours basic data object
and that most of the things are a
variation of the vector going one step
up from this is a matrix a matrix has
rows and columns it's two-dimensional
data on the other hand they all need to
be of the same length the columns all
need to be the same length and all the
data needs to be of the same class
interestingly the columns are not named
they're referred to by index numbers
which can make them a little weird to
work with
and then you can step up from that into
an array this is identical to a matrix
but it's for three or more dimensions
on the other hand probably the most
common form is a data frame this is a
two-dimensional collection that can have
vectors of multiple types you can have
character variables in one you can have
integer variables in another you can
have logical and a third the trick is
they all need to be the same length and
you can think of this as the closest
thing that R has that's analogous to a
spreadsheet and in fact if you import a
spreadsheet it's going to go into a data
frame typically now the neat thing is
that R has special functions for working
with data frames things that you can do
with those you can't do with others and
we'll see how those work as we go
through this course and through others
and then finally there's the list this
is ours most flexible data format you
can put basically anything in the list
it's an ordered collection of elements
and you can have any class any length
any structure and interestingly lists
can include lists and include lists and
so on and so forth so it gets like the
Russian nesting dolls you have one
inside the other one inside the other
now the trick is that may sound very
flexible it may very good it's actually
kind of hard to work with lists and so a
data frame really sort of the optimal
level of complexity for a data structure
and then let me talk about something
else here the idea of coercion now in
the world of ethics coercion is a bad
thing in the world of data science
coercion is good what it means here is
coercion is changing a data object from
one type to another it's changing the
level of measurement or the nature of
the variable that you're dealing with so
for example you can change a character
to a logical you can change a matrix to
a data frame you can change double
precision to integer you can do any of
these it's going to be easiest to see
how it works if we go to our and give it
a whirl so open up this script and let's
see how it works in our studio and for
this demonstration of datatypes we don't
need to load any packages we're just
going to run through things all on their
own
we'll start with numeric data and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to create a
data object a variable called n1 my
first numeric variable and then I use
the assignment operator that's this the
little left
and this right as n1 gets 15 now R does
double-precision by default let me do
this n1 then you can see that it showed
up here on the top right
if I call the name of that object it'll
show its contents in the console so I
just type n1 and run that and there you
can see in the console at the bottom
left it brought up a 1 in square
brackets that's an indexed number for
the first object in an array and this is
an array of one number but there it is
and we get the value of 15
also we can use the our command type of
to get a confirmation of what type of
variable this is and it's double
precision by default we can also do
another one where you do 1.5 we can get
its contents 1.5 and then we see that it
also is double precision we want to come
down and do a character I'm calling that
c1 for my first character variable you
see that I do see one the name of the
object I want to create I put the
assignment operator at the less-than and
- which is right as gets and then I have
in double quotes and other languages you
would do single quotes for a single
character and you would use double
quotes for Strings they're the same
thing in our and I put in double quotes
the lowercase C and that's just
something I chose so I feed that in you
can see that it showed up in the global
environment there on the right we can
call it forward and you see it shows up
with the double quotes on it
we've got the type of and it's a
character that's good
if we want to do an entire string of
text I can feed that into c2 just by
having it all in the double quotes and
we pull it out and we see that it also
is listed as a character even though in
other languages it would be called a
string
logical this is l14 logical first and
I'm feeding in true when you write true
or false they have to be all caps or you
can do just the capital T or the capital
F
that one out and it says true notice by
the way there's no quotes around it
that's one way you can tell it it's a
logical and not a character if we put
quotes into it it would be a character
variable
we've got the type of and there we go
it's logical
I said you can also use abbreviations so
for my second logical variable l2 I'll
just use F I feed that in and then you
see that it when I ask it to tell me
what it is it prints out the whole word
false and then we get the type of again
also logical then we can come down to
data structures I'm going to create a
vector which is a collection a one
dimensional collection and I'm doing it
by creating v1 for vector one and then I
use this C here
which stands for concatenate you can
also think of it as like combine or
collect and I'm going to put five
numbers in there you need to use a comma
between the values
and then I call out the object and
there's my five numbers notice it shows
them without the commas but I had to
have to calm was going in and then I
asked are is it a vector is period
vector and then asked about it and it's
just going to say true yes it is I can
also make a vector of characters I do
that right here
I get the characters and it's also a
vector and I can make a vector of
logical values true and false
call that
it's a vector also now a matrix you may
remember is in going in more than one
dimension in this case I'm going to call
it m14 matrix one and I'm using the
matrix function so I'm saying matrix and
then combine these values tte FFT F and
then I'm saying how many rows I want in
it and it can figure out the number of
columns by doing some math so I'm going
to put that into m1 and then I'll ask
for it and see now it displays it in the
rows and columns and it writes out the
full true or false
can do another one where I'm going to do
a second Matrix and this is where I
explicitly shape it and the rows and
columns now that's for my convenience
are doesn't care that I broke it up to
make the rows and columns but it's a way
of working with it and if I want to tell
it to organize it to go by rows I can
specify that with a biro equals T or
true command
I do that
and you see by the way that I have the
index numbers on the left are the row
index numbers that's Row 1 and Row 2 and
on the top are the column index numbers
and they come second which is why it's
blank and then one for the first column
and then blanket then two for the second
column then we can make an array what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to
create data and I'm going to use the
colon operator which says give me the
numbers 1 through 24 I still have to use
the concatenate to combine them and then
they give the dimensions of my array and
it goes rows columns and then tables
because I'm using three dimensions here
I'm going to feed that into an object
called array 1
right there you can see that I have two
tables in fact let me zoom in on that
one
and so it starts at the last level which
is the table
and then we have the rows and the
columns listed separately for each of
them
a data frame allows
to combine vectors of the same length
but of different types now what i'm
doing here is i'm creating a vector of
numeric values of character values and
logical values so these are three
different vectors but then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to use this
function c bind for a column bind to
combine them into a single data frame
i'm going DFA for data frame a or all
you
now the trick here is that we had some
unintentional coercion by just using SI
bind what it did is it coerced it all to
the most general format
I had numeric variables add character
variables and logical and the most
general is character and so it turned
everything into a character variable
that's a problem it's not what I wanted
I have to add another function to this I
have to tell it specifically make it a
data frame by using AZ dot data frame
when I do that
combined it and now you see it's
maintained the datatypes of each of the
variables that's the way I want it and
then finally I can do a list I'm going
to create three objects here object one
which is numeric with three values
object 2 which is character with 4 and
object 3 which is logical with 5
and then I'm going to combine them into
a list using the list function I'll put
them into list 1 and then we can see the
contents of list 1 and you can see it's
kind of a funky structure and it can be
hard to read but there's all the
information there and then we're going
to do something that's kind of you know
hard to get around logically is I'm
going to create a new list that has list
1 in it so I have the same three objects
plus I'm adding on to it list 1 so list
2 I'm gonna zoom in on that one and you
can see it's a lot longer and we've got
a lot of index numbers there in the
brackets there are the 3 integers the 4
character values and the 5 logical
values and then here they are repeated
but that's because they're all parts of
list 1 which I included in this list
and so those are some of the different
ways that you can structure data of
different types but you want to know
also that we can coerce them into
different types to serve our different
purposes the next thing we need to talk
about is coercing types now there's
automatic coercion we've seen a little
bit of that where the data automatically
goes to the least restrictive data type
so for instance if we do this where we
have a 1 which is numeric of B and
quotes which is character analogical
value and we feed them all into this
idea coerce one and by the way by
putting parentheses around it it
automatically saves it and shows us the
response
now you can see that what it's done is
it's taken all of them and made all of
them character because that's the least
specific most general format and so
that'll happen but you gotta watch out
because you don't want things getting
coerced when you're not paying attention
on the other hand you can coerce things
specifically if you want to have them go
in a particular way so I can take this
variable right here coerced to and we'll
put a 5 into that and we can get its
type and we see that it's double okay
that's fine
what if I want to make it integer then
what I do is I use this command as dot
integer
run that feet in to coerce three and it
looks the same when we see the output
but now it is an integer that's how it's
represented in the memory
I can also take a character variable and
here I have one two and three in quotes
which think them characters
get those and you can see that they're
all character but now I can feed them in
with this as dot numeric and it's able
to see that they are numerical numbers
in there and coerce them to numeric now
you see that it's lost the quotes and it
goes to the default double precision
probably the one you'll do the most
often is taking a matrix and that's just
let's take a look I'll make a matrix of
nine numbers and three rows and three
columns there they are and what we're
going to do is we're going to coerce it
to a data frame
now that doesn't change the way it looks
it's going to look the same but there's
a lot of functions you can only do with
data frames that you can't do with
matrices this one by the way will ask is
it a matrix and the answer is true but
now let's do this we'll do the same
thing and just add on as dot data dot
frame and now we tell it to make it a
data frame and you see it basically
looks the same it's listed a little
differently this one had its index
numbers here for the rows and the
columns this one is a row index and then
we have variable names across the top
and it's just automatically giving them
variables one two and three but the
numbers in it look exactly the same
on the other hand if we come back here
and ask is it a data frame we get true
and so it's a very long discussion here
but the point here is data comes in
different types and in different
structures and you're able to manipulate
those so you can get them in the format
and the type and the arrangement that
you need for doing your analyses in our
to continue our introduction and
accessing data we want to talk about
factors and depending on the kind of
work that you do this may be a really
important topic factors have to do with
categories and names of those categories
specifically a factor is an attribute of
a vector that specifies that possible
values and their order it's going to be
a lot easier to see if we just try it in
R and let me demonstrate some of the
variations just open up this script and
we can run through it together what
we're going to do here is create a bunch
of artificial data and then we're going
to see how it works first what I'm going
to do is I'm going to create a variable
X 1 with the numbers 1 through 3 and by
putting it in parenthesis here it'll
both store it in the environment and it
will display it in the console
so there we have three numbers 1 2 & 3
I'm going to create another variable Y
that's the numbers 1 through 9 so there
that is
now what I want to do is I want to
combine these two and I'm going to use
the see bind or column bind data frame
so it's going to put them together and
it's going to make them a data frame and
it's going to save them into a new
object I'm creating called DF for data
frame 1 and we'll get to see the results
of that let me zoom in on it a little
bit
and there you can see we have nine rows
of data we have one variable x1 that's
from the one that I created and then we
have Y and then we have the nine indexes
or the row IDs there down the side
please note that the first one x one
only had three values and so what it did
is it repeated it so you see it
happening three different times one two
three one two three
and what we want to find out is now what
kind of variable is x1 in this data
frame well it's an integer and we want
to get the structure it show is that
it's still an integer if we're looking
at this line right here
okay but we can change it to a factor by
using AZ dot factor and it's going to
react differently then so I'm going to
create a new one called x2 that again is
just the numbers one two and three but
now I'm telling our that those
specifically represent factors then
we'll create a new data frame using this
x2 that I saved as a factor and the one
through nine that we had and why
now at this point it looks the same but
if we come back to where we were and we
get the type of
it's still an integer that's fine but if
we get the structure of df2
now it tells us that X 2 instead of
being integer is a factor with three
levels and it gives us the three levels
in quotes 1 2 & 3 and then it lists the
data
if we want to take an existing variable
and define it as a factor we can do that
too
here I'll create yet another variable
with three values in it and then we'll
bind it to Y in a data frame
and then I'm going to use this one
factor right here and I'm going to tell
it to reclassify this variable x3 as a
factor and feed it into this same place
and that these are the levels of the
factor and because I put in parentheses
it'll show it to us in the console and
there we have it let's get the type it's
an integer but the structure shows it
again as a factor so that's one where we
could take an existing variable and turn
it into a factor
if you want to do labels we can do it
this way we'll do x4 again that's the
one through three and we'll bind it to
nine to make a data frame and here I'm
going to take the existing variable D f4
and then the variable is X 4 I'm going
to tell it the labels and then I'm going
to give them text labels I'm going to
say that there are Mac OS Windows and
Linux 3 operating systems
and please note I need to put those in
the same order that I want them to line
up to those numbers so one will be Mac
OS two will be Windows and three will be
Linux
run that through we can pull it up here
and now you can see how it goes through
and it changes that factor to the text
variables even though I entered it
numerically
if I want the type of to see what it is
it still calls it integer even though
it's showing me words and the structure
this is an important one let's zoom in
on that just for a second
the structure here at the bottom is it
says it's a factor with three levels and
it starts giving me the labels but then
it shows us that those are actually
numbers 1 2 & 3 underneath if you're
used to working with a program like SPSS
where you can have values and then you
can have value labels on top of them
it's the same kind of concept here
then I want to show you how we can
switch the order of things and this gets
a little confusing so try it a couple of
times and see if you can follow the
logic here we'll create another variable
x5 that's just the one two and three
will bind it to Y and there's our data
frame just like we've had in the other
examples
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take that new variable x5 in the data
frame 5d f5 and notice here I'm listing
the levels but I'm listing them in a
different order I'm changing the order
that I put them in there and then I'm
lining up these labels
when I run that through now you can see
the labels here maybe yes now baby yes
no it is showing us the nine values and
then this is an interesting one because
they're ordered it puts them with the
less than sign at each point to indicate
which one comes first which one comes
later we can take a look at the actual
data frame that I made while zoom in on
that
and you can see we know that the first
one's a 1 because when I created this it
was 1 2 3
and so the maybe is a 1 you see the cuz
it's the second thing here in each one
so 1 equals maybe but by putting it in
this order it falls in the middle of
this one there may be situations in
which you want to do that I just want
you to know that you have this
flexibility in creating your factor
labels in our
and finally we can check the type of
that and it's still an integer because
it's still coded numerically underneath
but we can get this structure and see
how that works and so factors give you
the opportunity to assign labels to your
variables and then use them as factors
in various analyses if you do
experimental research and this cut sort
of thing becomes really important and so
this gives you an additional possibility
for your analyses in R as you define
your numerical variables as factors for
using your own analyses
our next step in our an introduction in
accessing data is entering data so this
is where you're typing it in manually
and I like to think of this as a version
of ad hoc data because under most
circumstances you would import a data
set but there's situations in which you
need just a small amount of data right
away and you can type it in this way now
there are many different methods that
are available for this there's something
called the colon operator
there's seq which is for sequence there
see which is short for concatenate
there's scan and there's rep and I'm
going to show you how each of these work
I will also mention this little one the
less than and a dash that is the
assignment operator in our let's take a
look at it in our and I'll explain how
all of it works just open up this script
and we'll give it a whirl what we're
going to do here is just begin with a
little discussion of the assignment
operator the less than dash is used to
assign values to a variable so why it's
called an assignment operator now a lot
of other programs would use an equal
sign but we use this one that's like an
arrow and you read it as it gets
so X gets five it can go in the other
direction pointing to the right that
would be very unusual and you can use an
equal sign or knows what you mean but
those are generally considered poor form
and that's not just arbitrary if you
look at the Google style guide for our
it's specific about that
in our studio you have a shortcut for
this if you do option - it inserts the
assignment operator and a space so I'll
come down here right now do option - and
there you see so that's a nice little
shortcut you can use in our studio when
you're doing your ad hoc data entry
let's start by looking at the colon
operator and most of this you would have
seen already
and what this means is you simply stick
a colon between two numbers and it goes
to them sequentially so I'm doing x1 as
a variable that I'm creating and then I
have the assignment operator it gets 0
colon 10 and that means it gets the
numbers 0 through 10 and there they all
are
I'm going to delete my colon operator
that's waiting for me to do something
here
now if we want to go in descending order
just put the higher number first so I'll
put 10 : zero there it goes the other
way
scq or SEC is short for sequence and
it's a way of being a little more
specific about what you want now if you
want to we can call it the help on
sequence it's right over here for
sequence generation
there's the information
and we can do a sending values so SEC 10
duplicates 1 through 10 doesn't start at
0 starts at 1 but you can also specify
how much you want things to jump by so
if you want to count down in threes you
do 30 to 0 by negative 3 means step down
threes will run that one and because
it's in parenthesis it'll both save it
to the environment and it'll show it in
the consult right away
so those are ways of doing sequential
numbers and that can be really helpful
now if you want to enter an arbitrary
collection of numbers in different order
you can use C that's 10 for concatenate
you can also think of it as combine or
collect we can call it the help on that
one there it is and let's just take
these numbers and use C to combine them
into the data object x5 and we can pull
it and there you see it just went right
through an interesting one is scanned
and this is we're entering data alive
so we'll do scan here get some help on
that one you can see it read data values
and this one takes a little bit of
explanation I'm going to create an
object X 6 and then I'm feeding into it
scan with opening and closing
parentheses because I'm running that
command so here's what happens I run
that one and then down here in the
console you see that it now has one and
a colon and I can just start typing
numbers and after each one I hit enter
and I can type in however many I want
and then when you're done just hit enter
twice and it reads them all and if you
want to see what's in there come back up
here and just call the name of that
object there are the numbers that I
entered and so there may be situations
in which that makes it a lot easier to
enter data especially if you're using a
10 key
now Rep you can guess is for repetition
will call the help on that one replicate
elements
and here's what we're going to do we're
going to say x7 we're going to repeat or
replicate
true and we're going to do it five times
so
x7 and then if you want to see there are
our five throughs all in a row
if you want to repeat more than one
value it depends on how many things set
things up a little bit here I'm going to
do replicate or repeat for true and
false but by doing it as a set where I'm
doing the C concatenate to collect this
set what it's going to do is repeat that
set in order five times so a true false
true false true false and so on that's
fine but if you want to do the first one
five times and then the second one five
times I mean think of it as like
collating on a photocopier if you don't
want it collated you do each and that's
going to do true true true true true
false false false false false and so
these are various ways that you can set
up data and get it in really for an ad
hoc or an as-needed analysis and it's a
way of checking how functions work is
I've used in a lot of examples here and
you can explore some as possibilities
and see how you can use it in your own
work
the next step in our intro
and accessing data is talking about
importing data which will probably be
the most common way of getting data into
our now the goal here is you want to try
to make it easy get the data in there
get a large amount get it in quickly and
get processing as soon as you can now
there are a few kinds of data file so
you might want to import
there are CSV files that stands for
comma separated values and the sort of
the plain text version of a spreadsheet
any spreadsheet program can export data
as a CSV and nearly any data program at
all can read them
there are also straight text files txt
those can actually be opened up in text
editors and word processing documents
then there are xlsx and those are Excel
spreadsheets as well as the XLS version
and then finally if you're going to get
fancy you have the opportunity to import
in JSON
that's JavaScript object notation and if
you're using web data you might be
dealing with that kind of data now R has
built-in functions for importing data in
many formats including the ones I just
mentioned but if you really want to make
your life easy you can use just one a
package that I load every time I use R
is Rio which is short for our import
output and what Rio does is it combines
all of ours import functions into one
simple utility with consistent syntax
and functionality and makes life so much
easier let's see how this all works in
our just open up this script and we'll
run through the examples all the way
through but there is one thing you're
going to want to do first and that is
you're going to want to go to the course
files that we download at the beginning
of this course these are the individual
R scripts but is this folder right here
that's significant this is a collection
of three data sets I'm going to click on
that
and they're all called mbb and the
reason they're called that is because
they contain Google Trends information
about searches for Mozart Beethoven and
Bach three major classical music
composers and it's all about the
relative popularity of these three
search terms over a period of several
years and I have it here in CSV or comma
separated value format and as a text
file dot txt and then even as an Excel
spreadsheet
let's go to our and we'll open up each
one of these the first thing we're going
to need to do is make sure that you have
Rio now I've done this before that Rio
is one of the things I download every
time
so I'm going to use Pac Man and do my
standard importing or loading of
packages Surrealism now I do want to
tell you one thing significant about
Excel files and we're going to go to the
official our documentation for this if
you click on this it'll open up your web
browser and this is a shortcut web page
to the art documentation and here's what
it says I'm gonna actually read this
verbatim reading Excel spreadsheets the
most common are data import/export
question seems to be how do I read an
Excel spreadsheet this chapter collects
together advice and options given
earlier note that most of the advice is
for pre Excel 2007 spreadsheets and not
the later xlsx format
the first piece of advice is to avoid
doing so if possible if you have access
to Excel export the data you want from
Excel in a tab delimited or comma
separated form and use read elimb or
read CSV to import it into our you may
need to use read DLM 2 or read CSV 2 in
the locale that uses comment as the
decimal point exporting a diff file in
reading it using read diff is another
possibility okay so really what they're
saying is don't do it well let's go back
to our and I'm just going to say right
here you have been warned
but let's make life easy by using Rio
now if you've saved these three files to
your desktop then it's really easy to
import them this way we'll start with
the CSV we use Rio underscore CSV the
name of the object that I'm going to be
using to import stuff into and all we
need is this command import we don't
have to specify that as a CSV or say
that it has headers or anything we just
use import and then in quotes and in
parentheses we put the name and location
of the file so on a Mac it shows up this
way to your desktop
run that
and you can see that it just showed up
in my environment on the top right I'll
expand that a little bit I now have a
data frame
come back out let's take a look at the
first few rows of that data frame
Zoomer
you see we have months listed and then
the relative popularity of search for
Mozart Beethoven and Bach during those
months
and if I want to read the text file
which really nice is I can use the exact
same command import and I just give the
location in the name of the file I have
to add the dot txt but I run that and we
look at the head and you'll see it's
exactly the same no difference piece of
cake
what's nice about Rio is I can even do
the xlsx file now it helps that there's
only one tab in that file and that it's
set up to look exactly the same as the
others but when I do that rerun through
and you see that once again it's the
same thing Rio is able to read all of
these automatically makes life very easy
another neat thing is that our has
something called a data viewer now I'll
get a little bit of information on that
through help and you invoke the data
viewer let's do this one we do it with a
capital v for view and then we say what
it is we want to see and we'll do Rio
underscore CSV when we do that command
it opens up a new tab here and it's like
a spreadsheet right here and in fact
it's sortable we can click on this go
from the lowest to the highest and vice
versa and you see that mozart actually
is setting the range here
and that's one way to do it you can also
come over to here and just click on this
little it looks like a calendar but it
is in fact the same thing we can double
click on that and now you see we get a a
viewer of that file as well
going to close both of those
and I'm just going to show you the
built-in our commands for reading files
now these are ones that Rio uses on its
own and we don't have to go through all
this but you may encounter these in a
lot of existing code because not
everybody uses real and I want you to
see how they work
if you have a text file in this saved
and tab-delimited format you need the
complete address and you might try to do
something like this read dot table is
normally the command and you need to say
that you have a header that there's
variable names across the top but when
you read this it's going to get an error
message and it's you know it's
frustrating that's because they're
missing values in there in the top left
corner and so what we need to do is we
just need to be a little more specific
about what the separator is and so I do
the same thing when I say read table
there's the name of the file in its
location we have a header and this is
where I say this separator is a tab the
back score says that indicate this is a
tab so if I run that one
then it shows up it reads it properly
we can also do CSV the nice thing here
is you don't have to specify the
delimiter because CSV means that it's
comma separated so we know what it is
and I can read that one in the exact
same way and if I want to I can come
over here
I can just click on the viewer here and
I see the data that way also
and so it's really easy to import data
especially to use the package Rio which
is able to automatically read the format
and get it improperly and get you
started on your analyses as soon as
possible
now the part of our introduction that
maybe most of you were waiting for is
modeling data on the other hand because
this is a very short introductory course
I'm really just giving a tiny little
overview of a handful of common
procedures and in another course here at
data Lab CC we'll have much more
thorough investigations of common
statistical modeling and machine
learning algorithms but right now I just
want to give you a flavor of what can be
done in R and we'll start by looking at
a common procedure hierarchical
clustering or ways of finding which
cases or observations in your data
belong with each other more specifically
you can think of it as the idea of like
with like which cases are like other
ones now the thing is of course this
depends on your criteria how you measure
similarity how you measure distance and
there's a few decisions you have to make
you can do for instance what's called a
hierarchical approach which is what
we're going to do or you can do it where
you're trying to get a set number of
groups or that's called K the number of
groups you also have many choices for
measures of distance and you also have a
choice between it's called divisive
clustering where we start with
everything in one group and then you
split them apart or agglomerated which
is where they all start separately and
you selectively put them together but
we're going to try to make our life
simple here and so we're going to do the
single most common kind of clustering
we're going to use a measure of
Euclidean distance we're going to use
hierarchical clustering so we don't have
to set the number of groups in advance
and we're going to use a divisive method
we start with them all together and
gradually split them let me show you how
this works in our and what you'll find
is even though this may sound like a
very sophisticated technique in the lab
of the mathematics is sophisticated it's
really not hard to do in reality
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to use a data set that we use a
frequently I'm gonna load my default
packages to get some of this ready and
then I'll bring in the data sets we're
going to use Mt cars which if you recall
is Motor Trend Car road tests data from
1974 and there are 32 cars in there and
we're going to see how they group what
cars are similar to which other ones now
let's take a look at the first few rows
of data to see what variables we have in
here you see we have miles per gallon
cylinders displacement so on and so
forth not all of these are going to be
really influential or useful variables
and so I'm going to drop a few of them
and create a new data set that includes
just the ones I want if you want to see
how I do that I'm going to come back
here and I'm going to create a new
object a new data frame called cars and
this says it gets the data from empty
cars by putting the blank and the space
here that means use all of the roads but
here I'm selecting the columns c4
concatenate means I want columns 1
through 4 skip five six and seven skip
eight and then nine through 11 that's
why you're selecting my variables so I'm
going to do that and you see that cars
has now shown up at my environment
they're at the top right let's take a
look at the head of that data set well
zoom in on that one and they can see
it's a little bit smaller we have miles
per gallon cylinders displacement weight
horsepower quarter-mile seconds and so
on
now we're gonna do the cluster analysis
and we're going to find is it if we're
using the default it's super super easy
in fact I'm going to be using something
called pipes which is from the package D
plier which is why I loaded it is this
thing right here and what it allows you
to do is to take the results of one step
and feed it directly in as the input
data into the next step otherwise this
would be several different steps but I
can run it really quickly I'm going to
create an object called HC for
hierarchical clusters we're going to
read the cars data that I just created
we're going to get the distance or the
dissimilarity matrix which says how far
each observation is in Euclidean space
from each of the others and then we feed
that through the hierarchical cluster
routine H clust
saves it into an object and now we need
to do is plot the results we're going to
do plot HC my hierarchical cluster
object and then we got this very busy
chart over here but if i zoom in on it
and wait a second
you can see that is this nice little
it's called a dendrogram because has two
branches in the trees and looks more
like roots here you can see they all
start up together and then they split
and then they split and they split now
if you know your cars from 1974 and you
can see that some of these things that
makes sense so for instance here we have
the Honda Civic and the Toyota Corolla
which are still in production are right
next to each other
the Fiat 128 and the Fiat x19 or various
well they were both small Italian sports
cars they were different in many ways
but you can see that they're right next
to each other the Ferrari Dino the Lotus
Europa they make sense to put next to
each other if we come over here the
Lincoln Continental and the Cadillac
Fleetwood and the Chrysler Imperial it's
no surprise they're next to each other
what is interesting is this one here the
Maserati Bora
it's totally separate from everything
else because it's a very unusual
different kind of car at the time
now one really important thing to
remember is that the clustering is only
valid for these data points based on the
data that I gave it I only gave it a
handful of variables and so it has to
use those ones to make the clusters if I
gave it different variables or different
observations we could end up with a very
different kind of clustering but I want
to show you one more thing we can do
here with this clusters to make it even
easier to read let me zoom back out and
what we're going to do is draw some
boxes around the clusters we're going to
start by drawing
two boxes that have gray border so now
I'm gonna run that one and you can see
that it showed up and then we're going
to make three blue ones
four green ones and five dark red ones
and then let me come and zoom in on this
again and now it's easier to see what
the groups are in this particular data
set so we have here for instance the
Hornet for Drive the valiant the
mercedes-benz 450 SLC Dodge Challenger
and javelin all clumping together in one
general group and then we have these
other really big v8 American cars what's
interesting is akin is that the Maserati
Bora is off by itself almost immediately
it's kind of surprising because the Ford
Pantera has a lot in common with it but
this is a way of seeing based on the
information that I gave it how things
are clustered and if you're doing market
analysis if you're trying to find out
who's in your audience if you're trying
to find out what groups of people think
in similar ways this is an approach that
you're probably going to use and you can
see that it's really simple to set it up
at least using the default and R as a
way of seeing how you have regularities
and consistencies and groupings in your
data
as we go through our very brief
introduction to modeling data n are
another common procedure that we might
want to look at briefly is called
principal components and the idea here
is that in certain situations less is
more
that is less noise and fewer unhelpful
variables in your data can translate to
more meaning and that's what we're after
in any case now this approach is also
known as dimensionality reduction and I
like to think of it by an analogy you
look at this photo and what you see are
these big black outlines of people you
can tell basically how tall they are
what they're wearing where they're going
and it takes a moment to realize you're
actually looking at the photograph that
goes straight down and you can see the
people there on the bottom and you're
looking at their shadows and we're
trying to do a similar thing even though
these are shadows you can still tell a
lot about the people people are
three-dimensional shadows are
two-dimensional but we've retained
almost all of the important information
if you want to do this with data the
most common method is called principal
component analysis or PCA
and let me give you an example of the
steps metaphorically in pca you begin
with two variables and so here's the
scatterplot we've got X across the
bottom y at the side and this is just
artificial data and you can see that
there's a strong linear association
between these two well what we're going
to do is we're going to draw a
regression line through the data set and
you know it's they're about 45 degrees
and then we're going to measure the
perpendicular distance of each data
point to the regression line now not the
vertical distance that's what we would
do if we were looking for regression
residuals but the perpendicular distance
and that's what those red lines are then
what we're going to do is we're going to
collapse the data by sliding each point
down the red line to the regression line
and that's what we have there and then
finally we have the option of rotating
it so it's not on diagonal anymore but
it's flat
and that there is the PC the principle
component now let's recap what we've
accomplished here we went from a
2-dimensional data set to a
one-dimensional data set but maintained
some of the information in the data but
I like to think that we maintain most of
the information and hopefully we
maintained the most important
information in our data set and the
reason we're doing this is we've made
the analysis and interpretation easier
and more reliable by going from
something that was more complex
two-dimensional or higher dimensions
down to something that's simpler to deal
with fewer dimensions it means easier to
make sense of in general let me show you
how this works in our open up this
script and we'll go through an example
in our studio to do this well first need
to load our packages because I'm going
to use a few of these
load those don't load the data sets
now I'm going to use the MT Kars data
set we've seen it a lot
I'm going to create a little subset of
variables let's look at the entire list
of variables and I don't want all of
those in my particular data set so the
same way I did with hierarchical
clustering I'm going to create a subset
by dropping a few of those variables and
we'll take a look at that subset let's
zoom in on that and so there's the first
six cases in my slightly reduced data
set and we're going to use that to see
what dimensions we can get to that we
have fewer than the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
variables we here let's try to get to
something a little less see if we still
maintain some of the important
information in this data set
to do is we're going to start by
computing the PCA the principal
component analysis
we'll use the entire data frame here I'm
going to speed it into an object called
PC for principal components and there's
more than one way to do this in our but
I'm going to use PR Comp and this
specifies the data set that I'm going to
use and I'm going to do two optional
arguments one is called centering the
data which means moving them so the
means of other variables are 0 and then
the second one is scaling the data which
sort of compresses or expands the range
of the data so it's unit or variance of
one for each of them that puts all of
them on the same scale and it keeps any
one variable from sort of overwhelming
the analysis so let me run through that
and now we have a new object that showed
up on the right and if you want to you
can also specify variables by
specifically including them the tilde
here means that I'm making my prediction
based on all the rest of these and I can
give the variable names all the way
through and then I say what data said
it's coming from I say data equals empty
cars and I can do the centering and the
scaling there also it produces exactly
the same thing as just two different
ways of saying the same command
to examine the results we can come down
and get a summary of the object PC that
I created so I'll click on that and then
we'll zoom in on this and here's the
summary it talks about creating nine
components PC one for principal
component one to pc nine for principal
component nine you get the same number
of components that you had as original
variables
but the question is whether it divvies
up the variation separately now you can
take a look here at principal component
one it is the standard deviation of two
point three three nine one what that
means is if each variable began with a
standard deviation of one this one has
as much as two point four of the
original variables the second one has
one five nine and the others have less
than one unit a standard deviation which
means they're probably not very
important in the analysis
we can get a scree plot for the number
of components and get an idea on how
much each one of them explains of the
original variance and we see right here
I'll zoom in on that
our first component seems to be really
big and important our second one is
smaller but it still seems to be you
know above zero and then we kind of
grind out down to that one now there's
several different criteria for choosing
how many components are important what
you want to do with them right now we're
just eyeballing it and we see that
number one is really big number two sort
of a minor axis in our data
you want to you can get the standard
deviations and something called the
rotation here I'm going to just call PC
and then we'll zoom in on that in the
console to scroll back up a little bit
it's a lot of numbers the standard
deviations here are the same as what we
got from this first row right here so
that just repeats that the first one's
really big the second one's smaller and
then what this right here does what the
rotation is it says is what's the
association between each of the
individual variables and the nine
different components so you can read
these like correlations
I'm going to come back and let's see how
individual cases load on the PCs what I
do that is I could use predict run a
through pcs and then I feed those
results using the pipe and I round them
off so they're a little more readable
I'll zoom in on that
and here we've got nine
components listed and we got all of our
cars but the first two are probably the
ones that are most important so we have
here the PC one and two we see we've got
a giant value there are two point four
nine two seven three three five four and
so on
but probably the easiest way to deal
with all of this is to make a plot
what we're going to do is go something
with a funny name of by plot what that
means is a two-dimensional plot really
all it says is it's going to chart the
first two components but that's good
because based on our analysis it's
really only the first here that seemed
to matter anyhow so let's do the by plot
which is a very busy chart but if we
zoom on it we might be able to see a
little better what's going on here and
what we have is the first principal
component across the bottom and the
second one up the side and then the red
lines indicate approximately the
direction of each individual variables
contribution to these and then we have
each case we show its name about where
it would go now if you remember from the
hierarchical cluster a and the Maserati
Bora was really unusual and you can see
it's up there all by itself
and then really what we seem to have
here is displacement and weight and
cylinders and horsepower this appears to
be big heavy cars going in this
direction and we have the Honda Civic
that Porsche 911 Lotus Europa these are
small cars with smaller engines more
efficient these are fast cars up here
and these are slow cars down here and so
it's pretty easy to see what's going on
with each of these as in terms of
clustering the variables with a higher
clustering we clustered cases now we're
looking at clusters of variables and we
see that it might work to talk about big
versus small and slow verse as fast as
the important dimensions in our data has
a way of getting insight to what's
happening and directing us in our
subsequent analyses
let's finish our very short introduction
to modeling data and our with a brief
discussion of regression probably one of
the most common and powerful methods for
analyzing data I like to think of it as
the analytical version of e pluribus
unum that is out of many one or in the
data science sense out of many variables
one variable you want to put it one more
way out of many scores one score the
idea with regression is that you use
many different variables simultaneously
to predict scores on one particular
outcome variable and there's so much
going on here they'd like to think that
there's something for everyone
there are many versions and many
adaptations of regression that really
make it flexible and powerful for almost
no matter what you're trying to do we'll
take a look at some of these in R so
let's try it in R and just open up this
script and let's see how you can adapt
regression to a number of different
tasks and use different versions of it
when we come here to our script we're
going to scroll down here a little bit
and install some packages we're going to
be using several packages in this one
I'll load those ones as well as the data
sets package because we're going to use
a data set from that called US judge
ratings let's get some information on it
it is lawyers ratings of state judges in
the US Superior Court
and let's take a look at the first few
cases with head home
zoom in on that and what we have here
are six judges listed by name and we
have scores on a number of different
variables like diligence and demeanor
and whether it finishes with whether
they're worthy of retention that's the
RT en retention let's scroll back out
and what we might want to do is use all
these different judgments to predict
whether lawyers think that these judges
should be retained on the bench now
we're gonna use a couple of shortcuts
that can actually make working with
regression situations kind of nice first
we're going to take our data set we're
going to feed it into an object called
data so that shows up now in our
environment on the top right and then
we're going to define variable groups
you don't have to do this but it makes
the code really really easy to use plus
you find if you do this then you can
actually just use the same code without
having to redo it every time you do an
analysis so what we're going to do is
we're going to create an object called X
it's actually going to be a matrix and
it's going to consist of all of our
predictor variables simultaneously
and the way I'm going to do this is I'm
going to use as matrix and then I'm
going to say read data which is what we
defined right here and read all of the
columns except number twelve that's one
called retention that's our outcome so
the minus means don't include that but
do all the others so I do that and now I
have an object called X and then the
second one I say go to data and then
this you know blank means use all of the
rows but only read the twelfth column
that's the one that has a retention our
outcome so following standard methods X
those are all our variables and Y that's
our single outcome variable now the
easiest version of regression is called
simultaneous entry you use all of the X
variables at once throw them in one big
equation to try to predict your single
outcome and in art we use LM which is
for linear model and what we have here
is y as our outcome variable and then
the tilde means is predicted by or as a
function of X and then X is all of our
variables together being used as
predictors so this is the simplest
possible version and we'll save it into
an object called reg for regression one
and now if you want to be a little more
explicit you can give the individual
variables you can say that our 10
retention is a function of or as
predicted by all of these other
variables and then I say that they come
from the data set US judge ratings that
way I don't have to do the data and then
dollar sign before each of these they'll
give me the exact same thing so I don't
need to do that one explicitly
if you want to see the results we just
call on the object that we created from
the linear model and I'm going to zoom
in on that and what we have are the
coefficients this is the intercept start
with minus two and then for each step up
on this one at 0.1 0.36 so on and so
forth you'll see by the way that has
changed the name of each of the
variables to add the X because they're
in the data set X now that's fine
we can do inferential tests on these
individual coefficients by asking for a
summary we click on that and we'll zoom
in
and now you can see there's the value
that we had previously but now there's a
standard error and then this is the
t-test and then over here is the
probability value and the asterisks
indicate values that are below the
standard probability cutoff of 0.05 now
we expect the intercept to be below that
but you see for instance this one
integrity has a lot to do with people's
judgments of whether a person should be
retained and this one physical really
are they sick
and we have some others that are kind of
on their way and this is a nice one
overall and if you come down here you
can see the multiple r-squared it's
super high and what it means is that
these variables collectively predict
very very well whether the lawyers felt
that the judge should be retained let's
go back now to our script you can get
some more summary data here if you want
we can get the analysis of variance
table the ANOVA table and if we click on
that zoom in
there you can see that we have our
residuals and the why
come back out we do the coefficients
here are the regression coefficients we
saw those previously this is just a
different way of getting at the same
information we can get confidence
intervals
sumit on that and now we have a 95%
confidence interval so the two and a
half percent on the low-end the nine
seven and a half on the top-end in terms
of what each of the coefficients would
be
we can get the residuals on a
case-by-case basis let's do this one
and when we zoom in on that now this is
a little hard to read in and of itself
because they're just numbers but an
easier way to deal with that is to get a
histogram of the residuals from the
model so to do that when you just run
this command and then I'll zoom in on
this and you can see that it's a little
bit skewed mostly around zero we've got
one person way up on the high end but
mostly these are pretty good predictions
we'll come back out
now I want to show you something a
little more complicated we're going to
do different kinds of regression I'm
going to use two additional libraries
for this one is called Lars that stands
for at least angle regression and carrot
which stands for classification and
regression training will do that by
loading those two
and then we're gonna do a conventional
stepwise regression in which a lot of
people say there's problems with this
but I'm just gonna show that I'm gonna
do it really fast
there's our stepwise regression then
we're going to do something from laura's
called stage-wise it's similar to
stepwise but it has better
generalizability and we run that through
we can also do least angle regression
and then really one of my favorites is
the lasso that's the least absolute
shrinkage and selection operator
now I'm running through just the
absolute bare minimum versions of these
there's a lot more that we would wanted
to explore these but what I'm going to
do is compare the predictive ability of
each of them and I'm going to feed into
an object called r2 comp for a
comparison of the r-squared values and
here I specify where it is in each of
them I have to give a little index
number then we're going to round off the
values
Halon going to give them the name say
the first one stepwise and forward them
lower than last so and we can see the
values and what this shows us here at
the bottom is that all of them were able
to predict it super well but we knew
that because when we did just the
standard simultaneous entry there was
amazingly high predictive ability within
this data set but you will find
situations in which each of these can
vary a little bit maybe sometimes they
vary a lot but the point here is there
are many different ways of doing
regression and are makes those available
to whatever you want to do so explore
your possibilities and see what seems to
fit in other courses we will talk much
more about what each of these mean how
they can be applied and how it can be
interpreted but for right now I simply
want you note that these exist and they
can be done at least in theory in a very
simple way in our
and so that brings us to the end of our
an introduction and I want to make a
brief conclusion primarily to give you
some next steps other things that you
can do as you learn to work more with
our now we have a lot of resources
available here number one we have
additional courses on our in data Lab CC
and I encourage you to explore each of
them if you like art you might also like
working with Python another very popular
language for working in data science
which has the advantage of also being a
general-purpose programming language the
things that we do in our we can do
almost all the same things in Python and
it's nice to do a compare contrast
between the two with the courses we have
at data Lab CC and also recommend you
spend some time simply on the concepts
and practice of data visualization R has
fabulous packages for data visualization
but understanding what you're trying to
get and designing quality ones is sort
of a separate issue and so I encourage
you to get the design training from our
other courses on visualization and then
finally a major topic is machine
learning or methods for processing large
amounts of data and getting predictions
from one set of data that can be applied
usefully to others we do that for both R
and Python and other mechanisms here in
data lab take a look at all of them and
see how well you think you can use them
in your own work
now another thing that you can do is you
can try looking at the annual our user
conference which is user with a capital
R n an exclamation point there are also
local our user groups or rugs and I have
to say unfortunately there is not yet an
official our day but if you think about
September 19th its international Talk
Like a Pirate Day and we like to think
because pirates say our and so that can
be our unofficial day for celebrating
the statistical programming language are
any case I'd like to thank you for
joining me for this and I wish you happy
computing